This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in September, we sent 99PI producer a Christopher Johnson on a reporting trip to Atlanta. And that's where I met Merna Clayton, at her family home in a very chill, wooded suburb about seven miles west of downtown. Her parents decided to move here in the summer of 1972,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。早在九月，我们派《99PI》的制作人克里斯托弗·约翰逊去亚特兰大进行报道。就在那里，我见到了默娜·克莱顿，在市中心以西约七英里处一个非常宁静、树木繁茂的郊区，那是她的家。她的父母决定在1972年夏天搬到这里，
all because of a sleepover. I had a friend in elementary school, our name is Lecognia Glass, and I had the joy of being invited to come over to our house for a sleepover, and we had so much fun playing. I mean, what do second graders do? You don't know what second grade girls do, you run around and play.
这一切都源于一次留宿。我小学时有个朋友，名叫莱科尼亚·格拉斯，我有幸被邀请去她家过夜，我们玩得非常开心。我是说，二年级的孩子能做什么呢？你不知道二年级的女孩会做什么，就是到处跑着玩。
And getting to Lacania's house was magical. At the time, Mourna and Lacania lived in different neighborhoods. Mourna's community was a little more dense. Her home was nice, modest. And then Mourna's mom would drive her over to Lacania's. And wow. We had to go through these different streets and around very, it was almost like foresty. And so it was lots of trees and lots of houses. And it seemed like the houses as you got closer
去莱科尼亚家就像是一场奇幻之旅。当时，默娜和莱科尼亚住在不同的社区。默娜的社区稍微拥挤一些。她的家很不错，很朴素。然后默娜的妈妈会开车送她去莱科尼亚家。哇。我们得穿过不同的街道，绕过非常……感觉就像森林一样。到处都是树和房子。而且当你离得越来越近时，房子似乎也变得越来越大。
and closer got bigger and bigger and bigger. The neighborhood was lush, forested with oaks and hickories and of course, Georgia pines. The whole ride made Mernas little jaw drop. And it wasn't over. They'd get to Lacania's house, go up her driveway, and the entire time Mernagest stared at her friend's house, enchanted.
社区郁郁葱葱，长满了橡树、山核桃树，当然还有佐治亚松。整个车程让默娜的小嘴张得大大的。而且还没完。他们到达莱科尼亚家，开上车道，默娜全程都盯着朋友的房子，如痴如醉。
For a second grader, it was like going to Disneyland. You know, it was just huge. And then to go to the door and ring the doorbell, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. Little Mernna was so awestruck that she just couldn't stand it anymore. One day she came home from Lacanius and told her father she wanted to live in that neighborhood too. So within a year, we had moved here. So I was a daddy's girl, so my dad made a way. No way. So your father, the whole family, put everything in boxes
对于一个二年级的孩子来说，这就像去了迪士尼乐园。你知道，它太大了。然后走到门口按门铃，叮咚，叮咚，叮咚。小默娜被震撼得无法自拔。有一天她从莱科尼亚家回来，告诉父亲她也想住在那个社区。所以不到一年，我们就搬到这里了。我是个“爸爸的女儿”，所以我爸爸想办法实现了。真的吗？所以你父亲，全家人，把所有东西都装进箱子里，
and bought a house and moved for you. Yeah. Yeah. That's my daddy. For Mernus family and hundreds of others, this community was a 4,000 acres suburban jewel in the post-war south. It was called Collier Heights, and it was almost entirely black. Just as amazing as the expansive beauty is how this neighborhood came to be, especially
买了一栋房子，为了你搬了家。是的。是的。那就是我爸爸。对于默娜的家庭和成百上千的其他家庭来说，这个社区是战后南方一个占地4000英亩的郊区瑰宝。它被称为科利尔高地，而且几乎全是黑人。除了其广阔的美景令人惊叹外，这个社区的形成方式也同样令人惊奇，尤其是
given everything that stood in the way. Calgier Heights was established in the early 1950s when redlining and racial zoning all put hard limits on where black people could live. So in order to create this huge dreamy suburb, a team of community leaders used cold sharp strategy, flipping the logic of Jim Crow housing segregation on its head. It was the first time black Americans had the tactics and the resources to build for themselves a modern middle and upper class community on such a massive scale.
考虑到当时所面临的一切阻碍。科利尔高地建立于20世纪50年代初，当时“红线政策”和种族分区对黑人的居住地有着严格的限制。因此，为了创造这个巨大的梦想郊区，一群社区领袖运用了冷酷而敏锐的策略，彻底颠覆了吉姆·克劳法下的住房隔离逻辑。这是美国黑人第一次有策略和资源，以如此大规模地为自己建立一个现代化的中上层阶级社区。
["Massive Scale"] If a place like Call Your Heights was gonna emerge anywhere, it would be in Atlanta. Black Fogaf had particular experiences in a city such as Atlanta that have been unique unlike the American South. This is a special city for Black folk. I do not make any offensive about it. I love this city. Maurice Hopson teaches Africana studies at Georgia State. He has a book about Atlanta called The Legend of the Black Mecca. And certainly by the end of World War II, that was a well-known moniker for the city,
【“大规模”】如果像科利尔高地这样的地方要在某个地方出现，那一定是在亚特兰大。黑人在亚特兰大这样的城市有着独特的经历，这与美国南方其他地方不同。这对黑人来说是一个特殊的城市。我对此毫不避讳。我爱这座城市。莫里斯·霍普森在佐治亚州立大学教授非洲研究。他写了一本关于亚特兰大的书，名为《黑人麦加的传奇》。到二战结束时，这无疑是这座城市广为人知的绰号，
which drew black people from around the country. For close to a century, black Atlantis had been building successful businesses, earning higher ed degrees, and accumulating wealth and political power at levels few other cities could compete with, especially in the South. But this was still the deep south and Atlanta was deeply segregated, especially when it came to housing. In the mid 1940s, that system of segregation helped fuel a major housing crisis in the city. Atlanta's population was spiking with
它吸引了来自全国各地的黑人。近一个世纪以来，亚特兰大的黑人一直在建立成功的企业，获得高等教育学位，并积累了其他少数城市（尤其是在南方）无法比拟的财富和政治权力。但这仍然是深南部，亚特兰大种族隔离非常严重，尤其是在住房方面。20世纪40年代中期，这种隔离制度加剧了城市严重的住房危机。亚特兰大的人口因
wartime migrant labor and soldiers coming back home. And those soldiers wanted to, you know, make families. Men and women came back from the war and they wanted to get it in. I mean, you know, as part of the two. So we had this population surge, which means now you got a college education, you got a professional job, you got a family, you need a house for. Which meant a huge demand for new middle class housing. But if you were black, despite all that the mecha had to offer, finding that dream house
战时移民劳工和回国的士兵而激增。那些士兵想要，你知道，组建家庭。男男女女从战争中回来，他们想要……我是说，你知道，作为其中的一部分。所以我们经历了人口激增，这意味着现在你有大学学历，有专业工作，有家庭，你需要一栋房子。这意味着对新的中产阶级住房有着巨大的需求。但如果你是黑人，尽管“麦加”能提供这一切，找到那个梦想的房子
or any housing wasn't easy. Because for decades, most of Atlanta's black communities had been strictly segregated and confined to certain parts of the city. Even the black folks with money had to squeeze into just a few segregated neighborhoods with a limited number of houses and apartments. All of them are older and is set by a certain number of disadvantages. Andy Ways teaches history at San Diego State. He wrote a book about Black suburbanization called Places of Their Own. They're next to heavy industry, they're adjacent to a creek which floods
或者任何住房都不容易。因为几十年来，亚特兰大的大多数黑人社区都被严格隔离，并被限制在城市的特定区域。即使是有钱的黑人也必须挤在少数几个隔离的社区里，那里只有有限的房屋和公寓。所有这些房子都很旧，而且受到许多不利因素的影响。安迪·韦斯在圣地亚哥州立大学教授历史。他写了一本关于黑人郊区化的书，名为《他们自己的地方》。它们紧邻重工业，毗邻会泛滥的溪流，
when it rains, smoke, and rail lines that cross them, range of problems. They don't have any services. And as more and more people move to Atlanta, those neighborhoods, existing neighborhoods are filled to the bursting. Bursting or not, getting out of these neighborhoods was nearly impossible. For starters, the city had carved up downtown Atlanta into residential districts
下雨时，烟雾，穿过它们的铁路线，一系列的问题。它们没有任何服务。随着越来越多的人搬到亚特兰大，那些现有的社区已经人满为患。无论是否拥挤，离开这些社区几乎是不可能的。首先，这座城市将亚特兰大市中心划分为住宅区，
that were zoned by race. At the same time, the federal government wouldn't guarantee loans to black families, insisting they'd cause property values and white neighborhoods to tank. And on the rare occasion black home buyers did break through, things could get ugly. In the late 40s, a black beautician had just purchased her house in a white community west of downtown when it was dynamited, probably by an offshoot of the KKK. People who have the capacity to move beyond are being met by mobs, downtown when it was dynamited, probably by an offshoot of the KKK. People who have the capacity to move beyond are being met by mobs, by organized nightriders,
并按种族分区。与此同时，联邦政府拒绝为黑人家庭提供贷款担保，坚称他们会导致白人社区的房产价值暴跌。而在极少数黑人购房者取得突破的情况下，事情可能会变得很糟糕。40年代末，一位黑人美容师刚在市中心以西的一个白人社区买下房子，就被炸毁了，很可能是三K党的一个分支所为。那些有能力搬出去的人正遭到暴徒的袭击，
by a Ku Klux Klan, you know, and they're setting bombs in people's houses. Into this world of entrenched housing segregation and terrorism against black home buyers, stepped in activist named Robert Thompson, who helped find and end run around the whole system. Thompson was the housing secretary of Atlanta's urban league. He believed that housing could be used as a tool for racial progress. In the 1940s, he helped lead an effort to plot out more living spaces for black Atlantans. A lot more. Robert Thompson was terrific.
遭到有组织的夜间骑手，遭到三K党的袭击，你知道，他们在人们的房子里放置炸弹。在这个根深蒂固的住房隔离和针对黑人购房者的恐怖主义世界里，一位名叫罗伯特·汤普森的活动家站了出来，他帮助找到了绕过整个系统的方法。汤普森是亚特兰大城市联盟的住房秘书。他相信住房可以作为种族进步的工具。20世纪40年代，他领导了一项为亚特兰大黑人规划更多居住空间的努力。多得多。罗伯特·汤普森非常了不起。
Ron Bayer is a history professor at Georgia Tech, and he interviewed Thompson when Bayer was writing his book, Race and the Shaping of 20th Century Atlanta. He was involved in all the discussions that were going on during this time, involving where Blacks could be cleared to live. And so what they meant to earthly wanted to do, they wanted to set aside areas, Blacks could move in without meeting violence from whites, because it was already violence, erotic.
罗恩·拜尔是佐治亚理工学院的历史学教授，他在撰写《种族与20世纪亚特兰大的塑造》一书时采访了汤普森。他参与了当时所有关于黑人可以在哪里居住的讨论。所以他们真正想做的是，他们想划出一些区域，让黑人可以搬进去而不遭受白人的暴力，因为当时暴力已经很猖獗了。
That was a cute, cool thing. I can, I'll go ahead and lie. Recordings of Robert Thompson are rare, but in this 1985 interview with Ron Bayer, Thompson describes this sense of urgency when it came to housing and violence right after World War II. You lost that data. So really, you were certifying housing and that you could move into without any kind of voucher. Right.
那是一件很棒的事情。我可以，我会继续说。罗伯特·汤普森的录音很少见，但在1985年接受罗恩·拜尔采访时，汤普森描述了二战后住房和暴力问题带来的紧迫感。你丢失了那个数据。所以实际上，你是在认证住房，你可以搬进去而没有任何凭证。对。
The town was about to explode. The town was about to explode, Thompson said. So he and a group of prominent black Atlantans identified half a dozen so-called Negro expansion areas. These were small pockets spread around Atlanta that were very carefully plotted out in order to protect future black residents from violent white backlash.
“这座城市即将爆炸。”汤普森说。于是，他和一群杰出的亚特兰大黑人确定了六个所谓的“黑人扩张区”。这些是散布在亚特兰大周围的小口袋，经过非常仔细的规划，旨在保护未来的黑人居民免受白人的暴力反弹。
The group met with White Neighborhood Associations and they struck the so-called gentlemen's agreements to use highway, cemeteries, train tracks, and other landmarks as boundaries between the black expansion areas and white neighborhoods. Y'all stay on your side, we'll stay on ours. But these few small areas still weren't enough for a growing black Atlanta, and some of the city's black leadership disliked these gentleman's agreements just on principle.
该组织与白人社区协会会面，并达成了所谓的“绅士协议”，利用高速公路、墓地、铁轨和其他地标作为黑人扩张区和白人社区之间的边界。你们待在你们那边，我们待在我们这边。但这些少数小区域对于不断增长的亚特兰大黑人来说仍然不够，而且一些黑人领导层从原则上就不喜欢这些绅士协议。
They felt that agreeing to segregated boundaries was basically an endorsement of segregation. The irony is, of course, if you looked at the pretty sharply drawn racial barriers around them and boundaries around them, you would be looking at a map of Jim Crow segregation in vision to reach out into the foreseeable future of the city. So while the expansion areas went ahead, Thompson and his team decided around 1950 that it was time for a much bigger, bolder play, one that would harness Black Atlantis development know-how and its wealth.
他们认为，同意隔离边界基本上就是对种族隔离的认可。讽刺的是，当然，如果你看看周围那些画得非常清晰的种族障碍和边界，你看到的将是一张吉姆·克劳种族隔离的地图，旨在延伸到这座城市可预见的未来。因此，虽然扩张区计划继续进行，但汤普森和他的团队在1950年左右决定，是时候进行更大胆的尝试了，一个将利用亚特兰大黑人的发展专长及其财富的计划。
They called the plan Project X. Project X was the attempt to very simply not have whites aside with blacks could live. That was it. The whole thing was orchestrated by Atlanta's Urban League. They'd later write up this document on a typewriter, and the front page just said, Project X in all caps. Very special ops. It's sort of a manifesto, sort of a white paper. It lays out in cold, hard numbers and charts a crystal clear strategy to grab the West Side for Black development. Thompson's team surveyed land west of Central Atlanta. There were some white neighborhoods out there and a few small black communities. But to the west of all those, they saw a lot of undeveloped land
他们称这个计划为“X计划”。X计划的尝试非常简单，就是不让白人决定黑人可以住在哪里。就是这样。整个事情由亚特兰大城市联盟策划。他们后来用打字机写了一份文件，首页上用大写字母写着“X计划”。非常像特种作战。它既是一种宣言，也是一种白皮书。它用冷冰冰的数字和图表清晰地展示了夺取西区进行黑人开发的策略。汤普森的团队调查了亚特兰大市中心以西的土地。那里有一些白人社区和几个小的黑人社区。但在所有这些地方的西边，他们看到了大量未开发的土地，
that stretched all the way out to the county line. And they decide that they're going to try all the way out to the county line. And they decide that they're going to try to buy land further to the west. Thompson will survey all of the property ownership in a sloth of west Atlanta all the way to the chat at which you river. And they'd find ways to buy up that land and develop it. Since those parcels were outside the city limits, they weren't subject to Atlanta's race-based zoning loss, meaning black people could
一直延伸到县界。他们决定尝试一直买到县界。汤普森调查了亚特兰大西部一直到查塔胡奇河一带的所有房产所有权。他们会想办法买下那片土地并进行开发。由于这些地块在城市界限之外，它们不受亚特兰大基于种族的区划法的限制，这意味着黑人
still buy it if the owners were willing to sell. Thompson's team needed a strategy, and what they came up with was a plan to use racism in the real estate market to their advantage. White Atlanteans in the West Side were fearful of the arrival of African-Americans. The project X-Team knew that because they were black, they could depress the value of white owned space by simply buying property that was adjacent. The white owner would then likely be pressured to sell. And once those white communities found out that there were black people next door, those
如果业主愿意出售，仍然可以购买。汤普森的团队需要一个策略，他们想出的是利用房地产市场中的种族主义来为自己谋利。西区的白人亚特兰大人对非裔美国人的到来感到恐惧。X计划团队知道，因为他们是黑人，他们可以通过购买邻近的房产来压低白人拥有的空间价值。白人业主随后很可能会被迫出售。一旦那些白人社区发现隔壁有黑人，那些
residents were likely to move, and white home buyers would drop elsewhere. Either way, all of that space would then be open to black Atlanta. Manipulating Jim Crow psychology was just a tactic on the way to creating great black neighborhoods. Project X counted on the fear of a black neighbor. They undertake to use white fears of integration, white fears of living among or near African-Americans against whites to secure ownership of land and space for Atlanta's African-American West Side to grow. But they had to keep Project X kind of on the low. White communities were expanding too.
居民很可能会搬走，白人购房者会去别处。无论哪种方式，所有这些空间都将向亚特兰大黑人开放。操纵吉姆·克劳心理学只是创造伟大黑人社区的一种策略。X计划利用了对黑人邻居的恐惧。他们利用白人对融合的恐惧，利用白人对与非裔美国人生活在一起或附近的恐惧，来确保亚特兰大非裔美国人西区发展的土地和空间所有权。但他们必须对X计划保持低调。白人社区也在扩张。
And if they sensed that black developers wanted this land, they might snatch it up first, effectively cutting off the West Side to black people. One of Project X's first big steps was to assemble a group of 23 investors, including a few doctors, some teachers, a newspaper editor and a housewife. They formed a corporation, sold shares to raise money, and set their sites on more than a thousand acres. And then they went deep into the West Side and just started buying up land next to white communities which were caught completely unaware.
如果他们感觉到黑人开发商想要这片土地，他们可能会先抢走它，从而有效地切断黑人进入西区的途径。X计划的第一大步是召集了23名投资者，包括几名医生、一些教师、一名报纸编辑和一名家庭主妇。他们成立了一家公司，通过出售股份筹集资金，并将目标锁定在超过一千英亩的土地上。然后他们深入西区，开始购买白人社区旁边的土地，而白人社区对此完全不知情。
The white ignorance of the black community, but they didn't know. There was money in the black community and they began to jump over the white areas and create housing for themselves beyond that. So it began to encapsulate the white areas between two black areas. So the squeeze was on. Where the old plan for expansion areas had black neighborhoods surrounded by white homes, Project X flipped that. Black developers were now encircling white communities.
白人对黑人社区的无知，他们不知道。黑人社区里有钱，他们开始跳过白人区域，在白人区域之外为自己创造住房。所以它开始将白人区域包裹在两个黑人区域之间。所以挤压开始了。在旧的扩张区计划中，黑人社区被白人住宅包围，而X计划颠覆了这一点。黑人开发商现在包围了白人社区。
In neighborhoods around West Atlanta, locals started seeing these modern gleaming new middle-class houses go up on what used to be farmland or woods. White homeowners then watched in amazement as black families moved in. In just a couple of years, multiple white neighborhoods found themselves encircled. Robert Thompson described this strategy as both a leapfrog and a military-style pincer move. From a developing asset, I was color, a leapfrog pincer. So what we did, we jumped over. So then, these fights were pocketed. And we had jumped over, bought land.
在亚特兰大西部的社区里，当地人开始看到这些现代、闪亮的新中产阶级住宅在曾经是农田或树林的地方拔地而起。白人房主随后惊讶地看着黑人家庭搬进来。仅仅几年时间，多个白人社区发现自己被包围了。罗伯特·汤普森将这种策略描述为“蛙跳”和“军事式钳形攻势”。从一个发展资产来看，我是颜色，蛙跳钳形攻势。所以我们所做的是，我们跳了过去。所以，这些战斗被孤立了。我们跳了过去，买了地。
Nobody jumped stocking from buying land. Nobody can stop you from buying land," Thompson said. The project X strategy helped open up Atlanta's West Side for black development. The Pinser moves had worked brilliantly. Yeah, yeah, I would say that was right. Very good description coming out of the World War II era. The World War II generals would have been proud.
“没人能阻止你买地。没人能阻止你买地，”汤普森说。X计划策略帮助打开了亚特兰大西区进行黑人开发的大门。钳形攻势非常成功。是的，是的，我会说那是对的。二战时代非常好的描述。二战将军们会引以为豪的。
It came around the white area and caught them in between. And it will produce some of the most attractive, comfortable, expensive, as well as affordable, suburban-style housing that African Americans are able to purchase and live in anywhere in the United States in the 1950s and 60s. One of the places where these leapfrog tactics were used to best effect was out near a small suburb that was the original, all white, call your heights. In 1953, a black development company bought a thousand acres west of that white neighborhood, and the white folks lost it. Rumors spread that the whole area, including
它绕过了白人区域，将他们夹在中间。它将产生一些最具吸引力、舒适、昂贵以及负担得起的郊区风格住房，这是非裔美国人在20世纪50年代和60年代在美国任何地方都能购买和居住的。这些蛙跳战术效果最好的地方之一是靠近一个最初全是白人的小郊区——科利尔高地。1953年，一家黑人开发公司在那个白人社区以西买下了一千英亩土地，白人们彻底崩溃了。谣言四起，说整个地区，包括
their neighborhood of 135 homes, would soon be all black. They understood that if just one person sold, white-call your heights would fall like dominoes. The small community tried to form a united front. The Civic Club made it a moral issue, pressuring neighbors to stay loyal to the white race by holding the line. Those who wanted to sell were accused of being selfish. As one homeowner lamented, we sure do want to keep our property white, but their Negroes all around us now. Then just a few months, every white resident had sold their house to a black buyer. It was all over. White call your heights had become a black buyer. It was all over.
他们那135户住宅的社区，很快就会变成全黑人区。他们明白，如果只要有一个人卖掉房子，白人科利尔高地就会像多米诺骨牌一样倒下。这个小社区试图形成统一战线。市民俱乐部将其上升为一个道德问题，通过坚守阵地向邻居施压，要求他们对白人种族保持忠诚。那些想卖房的人被指责为自私。正如一位房主哀叹的那样：“我们确实想保持我们的房产是白人的，但现在我们周围都是黑人。”仅仅几个月，每一位白人居民都把房子卖给了黑人买家。一切都结束了。白人科利尔高地已经变成了
White called your heights had become a black community, just like that. Every house that you see that you're passing out, this was all white. We called it crack a bill. I wanted to see call your heights for myself, especially the front line that was once called Hightower Road, and how the whole area changed when it became
白人科利尔高地已经变成了一个黑人社区，就是这样。你经过看到的每一栋房子，这里曾经全是白人。我们称之为“白人区”。我想亲自看看科利尔高地，尤其是曾经被称为海特沃路的前线，以及当它变成
all black. Clarence Luckett's senior was more than happy to show me around. He's a deacon at Ebenezer back to his church, and he moved to call your heights in 1959. All this you see now, you pass, and there's no blacks live up this way. All down through here was white. All down everything left to right. He takes me past the wood frame houses that belong to the white community that used to live here. It really is like looking at the ruins of a segregated front line. It's when we turn and head west into call your heights
全黑人区时，整个地区是如何变化的。克拉伦斯·卢克特高级非常乐意带我四处看看。他是埃比尼泽浸信会教堂的执事，1959年搬到了科利尔高地。“你现在看到的所有这些，你经过，没有黑人住在这边。这里所有的地方曾经都是白人。从左到右的一切。”他带我经过那些属于曾经住在这里的白人社区的木结构房屋。这真的就像在看一个种族隔离前线的废墟。当我们转弯向西进入科利尔高地时，
that I can really appreciate the checkmate that jumping the whites, Pensermo. You can see the difference and we're going to make a left. You see the brick house on the heel a bit. Look at says right there in the architecture is proof that the squeeze tactic was a success. You just keep in mind all the brick was basically build by blacks for blacks. And you can see them as you come down to your right. These narrow asphalt rows roll and bend under a hunter-green canopy of magnolias and dogwoods. We drive by one ranch home,
我才能真正体会到“跳过白人”的钳形攻势所带来的将死局面。你可以看到区别，我们要向左转。你看到山坡上那栋砖房了吗？看，建筑本身就证明了挤压策略是成功的。你只需要记住，所有的砖基本上都是黑人为黑人建造的。当你向右转时，你可以看到它们。这些狭窄的沥青路在木兰花和山茱萸的猎人绿树冠下蜿蜒曲折。我们开车经过一栋牧场式住宅，
Pete colored brick, a window wall with cream curtains drawn against the sun. It sits like a crown on top of a grassy hill. The lawn is manicured and crisp. And this used to be a cool dude here and he had a convertible on his playboy. He lived here. It looks like a playboy house. He was there. He had a spance, a little car. And this was Dr. Roberts. We used to sit down this porch and talk about everybody and neighborhood. In the mid-1950s, this neighborhood became Atlanta's finest development for black people,
桃色的砖墙，一堵窗墙上挂着奶油色的窗帘，遮挡着阳光。它像皇冠一样坐落在一座长满草的山顶上。草坪修剪得整整齐齐，非常清爽。“这曾经是一个很酷的家伙住在这里，他有一辆敞篷车，他是花花公子。他住在这里。这看起来像是一栋花花公子别墅。他就在那里。他有一辆宽敞的小车。这是罗伯茨医生。我们过去常坐在门廊上谈论社区里的每个人。”20世纪50年代中期，这个社区成为了亚特兰大最优秀的黑人开发项目，
where houses went for $20 to $50,000. Today, the most expensive houses would run you more than $500,000. By the mid-1960s, Collier Heights was the dream, a modern 4,000-acre oasis. Black suburbanization was happening fast, especially across the South. But in terms of its sheer scale,
那里的房子售价在2万到5万美元之间。今天，最昂贵的房子要花你超过50万美元。到20世纪60年代中期，科利尔高地成为了梦想，一个现代化的4000英亩绿洲。黑人郊区化发展迅速，尤其是在南方。但就其规模而言，
its newness, and its status as a middle and upper middle class neighborhood, there was nothing else like Collier Heights anywhere in the country. Watching this house, my house, my house be built was exciting. Manette Coleman was in seventh grade when her parents had their house built from scratch. Sometimes when my father and mother would go look at it, I got to go look at the progress they were making with the house. And every day when we went to school, we took a bus that drove past the property. When the Colemans moved in in the 1960s, they joined a community of more than 5200 Black Atlantis living in call your Heights. Manette remembers her family's backyard
它的新颖性，以及作为中产和中上层阶级社区的地位，全国没有任何地方像科利尔高地这样。看着这栋房子，我的房子，我的房子被建造起来，真是令人兴奋。马内特·科尔曼上七年级时，她的父母从零开始建造了他们的房子。“有时当我的父亲和母亲去查看它时，我有机会去看看他们建造房子的进展。每天我们去学校时，我们都会坐公交车经过那处房产。”当科尔曼一家在20世纪60年代搬进来时，他们加入了一个由5200多名居住在科利尔高地的亚特兰大黑人组成的社区。马内特记得她家的后院
shaded by enormous Georgia pines. My cousin would come down from Washington, D.C. We'd get our books and we'd read for hours, just sitting under these big pine trees. And then as we got older, we'd sit under those pine trees and talk about boys. So... Oh!
被巨大的佐治亚松树遮蔽。“我的表亲会从华盛顿特区下来。我们会拿着书读上几个小时，就坐在这些大松树下。后来当我们长大后，我们会坐在那些松树下谈论男孩。所以……”哦！
That's it. That's it. That's it. That's it. That's it. Color Heights came to encompass 54 subdivisions, places like Kings Grant, Miami Heights, Christendot Valley, black Atlantins who drove out looking for their dream homes would park and take footpaths up through vast front lawns. They'd tour split-level homes that sometimes went three, four, even five stories down the
就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。科利尔高地最终包含了54个分区，像国王赠地、迈阿密高地、克里斯滕多特谷这样的地方，开车出来寻找梦想家园的亚特兰大黑人会停车，沿着小路走上广阔的前草坪。他们会参观分层住宅，有时甚至会向后延伸三、四、甚至五层楼。
back of Hell. Call your Heights had a whole rainbow of ranch styles. Compact, linear, linear with clusters, bungalow, alphabet. Some of them designed by the best architects in the game. There were homes with pagoda-inspired roofs, and others designed in a style called the woodland master deluxe split level. There was one house, it's still there, built in the round for perfect acoustics, custom made for the local high school band director. As for Manette Coleman's home, she can still picture it on the inside.
科利尔高地有各种各样的牧场风格。紧凑型、线性型、带集群的线性型、平房、字母型。其中一些由业内最好的建筑师设计。有带有宝塔风格屋顶的房屋，还有以“林地大师豪华分层”风格设计的房屋。有一栋房子，它还在那里，为了完美的声学效果而建成圆形，是为当地高中乐队指挥定制的。至于马内特·科尔曼的家，她仍然能想象出里面的样子。
How could I forget it? First of all, it was back in the days when avocado green was popular. So every damp thing in that house, almost everything, it was green. The main bathroom was green. The living room kitchen was painted green. I think the day never has a style and color complemented each other so perfectly as mid-century modern and
“我怎么能忘记它呢？首先，那是在鳄梨绿流行的年代。所以那房子里的每一件该死的东西，几乎所有东西，都是绿色的。主浴室是绿色的。客厅厨房漆成了绿色。”我想，没有任何一种风格和颜色能像中世纪现代风格和
avogado green. And then there were steps going down to this basement. The basement was the full length of the house. That basement was so big we would do races on bikes and scooters and wagons and stuff like that. We were going around the stairs. It was like the chariot race and been her or something like that. In an Ebony magazine feature from 1971,
鳄梨绿那样完美地互补。然后有通往地下室的台阶。地下室是房子的全长。那个地下室太大了，我们会在上面骑自行车、滑板车、马车之类的东西进行比赛。我们绕着楼梯转。就像《宾虚》里的战车比赛之类的东西。在1971年的一期《乌木》杂志专题中，
titled Atlanta, Black Mecca of the South, call your heights was described as one of just a few verdant neighborhoods that are the true pride and joy of the city's black citizenry. The neighborhood had also become a who's who of successful black Atlanta. If you was anybody or somebody that had a dollar, you lived in Call your Heights.
标题为《亚特兰大，南方的黑人麦加》，科利尔高地被描述为“该市黑人公民真正的骄傲和喜悦的少数几个郁郁葱葱的社区之一”。这个社区也成为了亚特兰大成功黑人的名人录。如果你是任何有钱的人，你就住在科利尔高地。
All doctors, you could find them in Call your Heights. All preachers had the big churches in Call Your Hites. My tour guide, Clarence Luckett, one of his mentors was Reverend Martin Luther King Senior. Around Call Your Hites, they call him Daddy King. He had a house there, and so did Ralph Abernathy, the civil rights leader who was a best friend and close advisor to Martin Luther King, Jr. Manette Coleman's dad was George Coleman, editor of the Atlanta Daily World,
“所有的医生，你都能在科利尔高地找到他们。所有的牧师都在科利尔高地有大教堂。”我的导游克拉伦斯·卢克特，他的导师之一是马丁·路德·金牧师的父亲。在科利尔高地周围，他们叫他“金爸爸”。他在那里有一栋房子，拉尔夫·阿伯内西也是，那位民权领袖，他是马丁·路德·金的挚友和亲密顾问。马内特·科尔曼的父亲是乔治·科尔曼，《亚特兰大每日世界报》的编辑，
one of the oldest black newspapers in the country. There was a bank president, at least two state congressmen, greedy hospitals, medical tractor, several architects and lawyers. Mernick Clayton remembers her neighborhood got so famous for its illustrious residence and gorgeous homes, it became a straight up tourist attraction. When I was younger, two buses used to come down the street. People wanted to see, you know, call your heights. And so I'd be waving at the bus going past, but there would be big, greyhound size buses. Not everyone in call your heights was famous or part of the wealthy elite.
这是全国最古老的黑人报纸之一。那里有一位银行行长，至少两名州议员，贪婪的医院，医疗拖拉机，几位建筑师和律师。默娜·克莱顿记得她的社区因为其杰出的居民和华丽的住宅而变得如此出名，以至于它直接成为了一个旅游景点。“当我年轻的时候，两辆公交车经常开过这条街。人们想看，你知道，科利尔高地。所以我会在公交车经过时挥手，但那会是灰狗大小的大巴。”并非科利尔高地的每个人都是名人或富有精英的一部分。
Some were HBCU professors, laborers, clerks and librarians. Some were strivers who scraped together just enough to buy themselves and their families. Some of the good life out there. A lot of those people got in those houses by doing jobs that were menial. They built up a business, but before that, you know, in college, a lot of them waited tables. Some of them may not have even gone to college. Some of them had worked for white folks saw how they lived and said, hmm, this is how the better half lives is how I want to live.
有些人是HBCU（历史悠久的黑人学院和大学）的教授、劳工、职员和图书管理员。有些人是努力奋斗的人，他们攒够了钱为自己和家人买下了一点好生活。很多人进入那些房子是因为他们从事的是卑微的工作。他们建立了一项事业，但在那之前，你知道，在大学里，他们中的许多人做过服务员。有些人甚至可能没有上过大学。有些人为白人工作，看到了他们的生活方式，然后说，嗯，这就是另一半人生活的方式，这就是我想生活的方式。
By the early 1970s, the community had grown to include 2,000 homes built from scratch. This was peak call your heights. For the people who live there, the neighborhood had become more than just a solution to a housing crisis in a segregated city. Black folks wanted in on the suburban dream, and call your heights, it promised to make it come true tenfold.
到20世纪70年代初，社区已经发展到包括2000栋从零开始建造的房屋。这是科利尔高地的鼎盛时期。对于住在那里的人来说，这个社区不仅仅是解决了一个种族隔离城市中的住房危机。黑人想要实现郊区梦，而科利尔高地承诺让它十倍地实现。
Along with peace and fresh air, this cloistered all black suburb offered even a small break from white racism. Collier Heights was also a space where some upper-dly mobile black people could distinguish their community from lower income neighborhoods. And in general, Black Atlanta was proud that a space so grand had been made for and by black people. Collier Heights was also celebrated for showing the world a vision of black
除了宁静和新鲜空气，这个与世隔绝的全黑人郊区甚至提供了一点点远离白人种族主义的喘息机会。科利尔高地也是一些向上流动的黑人可以将他们的社区与低收入社区区分开来的空间。总的来说，亚特兰大黑人很自豪，一个如此宏伟的空间是由黑人为了黑人而创造的。科利尔高地也因向世界展示了黑人进步的愿景而受到赞誉。
progress. Proof that black folks wanted to and could live well, even luxuriously, in suburbia. For its residents, call your Heights represented the epitome of self-determination and dignity in a world of entrenched anti-blackness, a world where white Atlantans worked very hard to exclude them from certain communities. Black folks say, well that's fine. You don't want to associate with us? Fine. We don't have to associate with you. And we can survive and be okay. You know, and so we don't have to be in your world. We'll create our own world. We already know how to build. We know how to, we got the skills.
证明了黑人想要并且能够在郊区生活得很好，甚至是奢侈地生活。对于它的居民来说，科利尔高地代表了在根深蒂固的反黑人世界中，自决和尊严的缩影，一个白人亚特兰大人非常努力地将他们排除在某些社区之外的世界。黑人说，好吧，那没关系。你不想和我们交往？没关系。我们不必和你交往。我们可以生存并过得很好。你知道，所以我们不必在你的世界里。我们将创造我们自己的世界。我们已经知道如何建造。我们知道如何，我们有技能。
Black people get a lot of hand-me-downs from laws and legislations to clothes and shoes and everything like that. My parents deserve the brand new house. They deserved new. They deserved everything that that house had to offer. A good neighborhood, good schools, close to the church, and a house that didn't come with somebody else's memories, they created everything in there on their own. In 2009, nearly 50 years after the Coleman's moved into their home, Collier Heights was listed on the National Register of Historic Places. The community was officially not new anymore.
黑人从法律和立法到衣服和鞋子等等，得到了很多二手货。我的父母理应得到全新的房子。他们理应得到新的东西。他们理应得到那栋房子所能提供的一切。一个好的社区，好的学校，靠近教堂，以及一栋没有带着别人记忆的房子，他们自己创造了里面的一切。2009年，在科尔曼一家搬进他们家近50年后，科利尔高地被列入《国家史迹名录》。这个社区正式不再是“新的”了。
It was also a lot smaller than it used to be. The neighborhood boundaries were redrawn, shrinking Collier Heights down to a historic core that's less than a quarter of its original size. There have been other changes too. In recent decades, some residents have put ornate wrought iron bars on their windows and doors for safety. Lones have gotten a bit shaggy, and some of the houses could stand a little TLC.
它也比过去小了很多。社区边界被重新划定，将科利尔高地缩小到一个不到其原始规模四分之一的历史核心区。还有其他变化。近几十年来，一些居民为了安全，在窗户和门上安装了华丽的锻铁栅栏。草坪变得有点杂乱，有些房子需要一点点呵护。
Back up his house, and he had a big ol' swimming pool in the back of his house, and these are the so-called elite black folks with some duckies in there. As Clarence Luckett drives me around, pointing out this doctor's home here, and that lawyer's house over there, we talk about probably the biggest change
“回到他的房子，他在房子后面有一个大游泳池，这些是所谓的精英黑人，里面有一些小鸭子。”当克拉伦斯·卢克特带我四处看看，指着这位医生的家，那边那位律师的房子时，我们谈到了科利尔高地可能发生的最大变化。
in call your heights. It's greatest resource that first generation of homeowners is passing away. Sometimes the younger generations can't or don't really want to take care of the house, which can lead to neglect. This is the doctor's house over the right. He wanted to build all of these.
它最大的资源，第一代房主正在去世。有时年轻一代不能或真的不想照顾房子，这可能导致忽视。“这是右边那位医生的房子。他想建造所有这些。”
He's dead and his family won't move in the house. But to see how it's weeded up a little. Many of those kids have their own homes and they're not interested in living and call your heights. And at Coleman explains that parents like hers wanted their kids to be among the best educated to get great jobs and to have zero limits on where they could travel and live.
“他去世了，他的家人不想搬进这栋房子。但看到它长了一些杂草。许多孩子有自己的房子，他们对住在科利尔高地不感兴趣。”科尔曼解释说，像她父母那样的父母希望他们的孩子受到最好的教育，找到很棒的工作，并且在他们可以旅行和居住的地方没有任何限制。
The plan worked and for a while it was hard to convince those kids and other younger families to move back to the neighborhood. You see houses that went up for sale and nobody has bought them because they look like mansions, but nobody who wants to live in a mansion wants to live and carve your heights. But that's changing too. Minutes family just sold their home to a man who has big plans to renovate. Neighbors say they're seeing more and more strangers, both black and white,
计划奏效了，有一段时间很难说服那些孩子和其他年轻家庭搬回社区。你看到挂牌出售的房子，没有人买，因为它们看起来像豪宅，但没有想住豪宅的人想住在科利尔高地。但这种情况也在改变。默娜的家人刚刚把他们的家卖给了一个有宏大翻新计划的人。邻居们说他们看到越来越多的陌生人，无论是黑人还是白人，
passed through the community, not tourists, but people who want to buy. With as much intention as it took to build this jewel of the black mecca, Clarence Lucky believes they've got to preserve it by retelling and handing down the epic of call your heights. It's going to have to be parents like me. Let their kids know that always should be a home house, or old church, that you can bring your great, great grand set.
穿过社区，不是游客，而是想买房的人。克拉伦斯·卢克特认为，为了建立这个“黑人麦加”的瑰宝，他们必须通过重述和传承科利尔高地的史诗来保护它。“这将不得不像我这样的父母。让他们的孩子知道，那应该是一个家，或者老教堂，你可以带你的曾曾孙子去。”
This is where grandmama lives. Call your heights might not have the conveniences of a trendy Atlanta neighborhood, but what gives this community its weight is that powerful origin story. Everything that went into carving out a space that was, as the locals say, for us by us. Now, you take my dad and he was born in 1898, maybe. My granddaddy was a slave. They didn't have nowhere to go back to the shoulder of kids. See, so what we have to tell our kids about this neighborhood is the history of what your grandparents had to do just to live in this neighborhood. The only way things can be
“这就是奶奶住的地方。”科利尔高地可能没有时髦的亚特兰大社区的便利设施，但赋予这个社区分量的是那个强大的起源故事。所有为了开辟一个正如当地人所说的“为了我们，由我们”的空间所付出的努力。现在，你看看我爸爸，他出生于1898年，也许。我爷爷是个奴隶。他们没有地方可以回到孩子们的肩膀上。所以，我们必须告诉我们的孩子关于这个社区的历史，关于你的祖父母为了住在这个社区所必须做的事情。唯一能让事情成为
history, somebody got to pass it on. When we come back for the Coda, we're going to talk about the thing that all people talk about in the suburbs, even historic groundbreaking suburbs. We're going to talk about lawns after this. We're back with Christopher Johnson, Hey Christopher. Hey, Roman. So, obviously, I went to Atlanta to work on this story. And this was my first time out in the field since the COVID lockdowns.
历史的方法，就是有人必须把它传下去。当我们回来进行尾声时，我们将谈论所有人在郊区谈论的事情，即使是历史性的开创性郊区。我们将在之后谈论草坪。我们和克里斯托弗·约翰逊回来了，嘿克里斯托弗。嘿，罗曼。所以，显然，我去了亚特兰大做这个故事。这是我自新冠封锁以来第一次在实地工作。
And so what was that like? What did you do? One of my first apps was barbecue. Oh, that's all right. Perfectly fine. But I also got to hang out and call your heights, which was really great, because I got to meet some pretty wonderful people
那是什么感觉？你做了什么？我的第一站之一是烧烤。哦，那没关系。完全没问题。但我也有机会在科利尔高地闲逛，这真的很棒，因为我遇到了一些非常棒的人，
and just spend some time. Some folks, I sat down with them and they're living rooms and we just talked, uh, classic Southern hospitality. And in the course of talking to a lot of different people, I came across a whole other part of this story about call your heights that I didn't get to talk about earlier. Um, as I chatted with some folks there, people who are from, call your heights, people who grew up there, was one thing kept coming up over and over again, which was lawn care. Okay, this is interesting. Lones are very fraught, the subjects, when it comes to home ownership. So I'm intrigued to how it, the flavor of it and call your heights.
只是花了一些时间。有些人，我和他们坐在客厅里，我们只是聊天，经典的南方好客。在与许多不同的人交谈的过程中，我发现了关于科利尔高地的另一个故事，我之前没能谈到。嗯，当我与那里的一些人聊天时，那些来自科利尔高地的人，那些在那里长大的人，有一件事反复出现，那就是草坪护理。好吧，这很有趣。草坪是非常令人担忧的话题，当涉及到房屋所有权时。所以我很感兴趣它在科利尔高地的味道。
A lot of it was prompted by me asking people, how call your heights had changed in the last few decades. And the grass kept coming up over and over again. So for example, you remember Mernick Clayton from the story. Yeah, she's the opening anecdote. She's the one who's like, dad bought her a house and call your heights because she had just magical sleepovers there. Exactly. That Mernick Clayton. So I asked her about changes in the community in the last few decades. And one of her issues was the grass and neighbors just not taking care of their front lawns anymore. People parking on grass, that's not something that we did.
很多是由我问人们科利尔高地在过去几十年里发生了什么变化引起的。草坪的问题反复出现。例如，你还记得故事里的默娜·克莱顿吗？是的，她是开篇的轶事。她是那个说她爸爸给她买了一栋科利尔高地的房子，因为她在那儿有过神奇的留宿经历的人。正是那位默娜·克莱顿。所以我问她关于过去几十年社区的变化。她的问题之一是草坪，邻居们不再照顾他们的前草坪了。人们把车停在草地上，那不是我们做的事情。
People not cutting their grass, it's just not something we did. We always took care of our lawns, where that's just not something that a number of people know how to do. Yes, I've heard this before. I mean, lawn care or lack of it is probably the most suburban complaint ever. And it's like driven plenty of neighborhood associations
人们不割草，那不是我们做的事情。我们总是照顾我们的草坪，那不是很多人知道怎么做的事情。是的，我以前听说过这个。我是说，草坪护理或缺乏护理可能是最郊区的抱怨了。它促使许多社区协会
to draft bylaws about upkeep and all kinds of things to control people and what they do with their lawns. Absolutely, yeah. Absolutely. And a lot of it is about class values. So like for example, and call your heights, from the beginning, this neighborhood was a space for Atlantis, middle, and upper class.
起草关于维护的章程和各种各样的事情来控制人们以及他们如何处理草坪。绝对，是的。绝对。很多是关于阶级价值观的。所以，例如，在科利尔高地，从一开始，这个社区就是亚特兰大中产和上层阶级的空间。
And one of the things that held that together is middle and upper class values. And you know, it's like you go to those old-school houses with those old-school living rooms. I used to see this when I would go visit my aunts and uncles in suburban Maryland and NDC, where they have these living rooms that aren't touched unless you have company. There's a family room and the play room, but the living room is for a special company and otherwise for a display. Front lawns are preserved for show.
支撑这一切的事情之一是中产和上层阶级的价值观。你知道，就像你去那些老派的房子和那些老派的客厅一样。我过去常看到这种情况，当我去看望我在马里兰州郊区和华盛顿特区的阿姨和叔叔时，他们有这些客厅，除非你有客人，否则不会被触碰。有一个家庭活动室和游戏室，但客厅是为特殊的客人准备的，否则就是为了展示。前草坪是为展示而保留的。
They captured the way that you wanted to present your family to the world. It's like putting on your best outfit to step out into the world or go to a job interview or whatever, right? And I think that in a lot of ways, that's part of what's going on with the front lawn. And you mentioned everyone, not just Mourna was talking about lawns. What other people say about it?
他们捕捉到了你想要向世界展示家庭的方式。这就像穿上你最好的衣服去面对世界，或者去参加面试等等，对吧？我认为在很多方面，这正是前草坪所代表的一部分。你提到了每个人，不仅仅是莫娜在谈论草坪。其他人是怎么说的？
Yeah, I mean, I met this wonderful couple and they had some pretty strong feelings about lawns too. This is Harold and Winita Morton. Winita is the vice president of the Call Your Heights Community Association. Harold is the former president and they were really Heights Community Association. Harold is the former president and they were really helpful with this story and they were super generous. They gave me a tour of their home and they introduced me to a lot of wonderful neighbors including Clarence Luckett's Senior. And when we sat down in their living room to talk about Call Your Heights, this neighborhood that they love, Harold Morton went even further than Murna about lawns. Even something as simple as cutting your grass.
是的，我遇到了一对很棒的夫妇，他们对草坪也有很强烈的看法。这是哈罗德和威妮塔·莫顿。威妮塔是科利尔高地社区协会的副主席，哈罗德是前任主席。他们在这个故事上提供了很多帮助，而且非常慷慨。他们带我参观了他们的家，并向我介绍了许多很棒的邻居，包括克拉伦斯·拉基特。当我们坐在他们的客厅里谈论他们热爱的科利尔高地社区时，哈罗德·莫顿对草坪的看法甚至比莫娜还要深入。即使是像割草这样简单的事情。
I just don't get it and you get neighbors that like the park to cars on the grass. So I'm not elitist, but you're not supposed to wire on the grass. So I'm not elitist, but you're not supposed to work on the grass. Carrier Heights, you never park your car on a grass. You never had a barbecue's in the front yard. That's why we have backyards. Some people in front yard people,
我就是不明白，有些邻居喜欢把车停在草坪上。我不是精英主义者，但你不应该在草坪上停车。在科利尔高地，你绝不能把车停在草坪上。你绝不能在前院烧烤。这就是为什么我们有后院。有些人是前院派，
some people in back yard people. I mean, but Carrier Heights were built for back yard people. I mean, but Carl Hites will be built for backyard people. I mean, you may have a few front porches, but the majority of entertaining, you're grilling, you're swimming pools, you're trampolines, everything's in the back. You invite your neighbors to the backyard to party.
有些人是后院派。我的意思是，科利尔高地是为后院派建造的。我的意思是，你可能有一些前廊，但大部分娱乐活动，比如烧烤、游泳池、蹦床，一切都在后面。你会邀请邻居到后院聚会。
But now, you know, you got front yard people. There's a lot to unpack there. Front yard people and back yard people. I have never heard that before, but I totally know what he's talking about. I mean, so, I mean, I guess we're interested in when it comes to Harold here is like how he can talk and think in this way and also not wanna come off as a leadist.
但现在，你知道，有了前院派。这里面有很多值得深究的地方。前院派和后院派。我以前从未听说过，但我完全明白他在说什么。我的意思是，我想我们感兴趣的是，当谈到哈罗德时，他是如何以这种方式思考和说话，同时又不想显得像个精英主义者。
You know what I mean? Like what is that contradiction about? Yeah, so, elitism and class are really complicated things in places like call your heights, which is partly why you hear this balancing act in Harold's voice. It's connected to the community's origin story because on the one hand, call your heights has deep ties to the civil rights movement.
你明白我的意思吗？那种矛盾是什么？是的，精英主义和阶级在科利尔高地这样的地方是非常复杂的事情，这也是为什么你在哈罗德的声音中听到这种平衡感的部分原因。这与社区的起源故事有关，因为一方面，科利尔高地与民权运动有着深厚的联系。
I mentioned the kings, also the Abernathes, civil rights activists would hold fun raisers out and call your heights because that's where the money was, and also that's where they found folks who empathize with the struggle. And as we said earlier, many of the folks in call your heights came straight from the struggle. They were strivers or at least their parents were. So that's on the one hand. On the other hand, Call Your Heights is long pride at itself when it ties to the black elite. And there's no real reason why black folks wouldn't be elitist. So it's a delicate thing, upholding middle class values that can sometimes smack of elitism, while not coming off as elitists because that could betray the spirit of the community.
我提到了金博士，还有阿伯内西一家，民权活动家会在科利尔高地举行筹款活动，因为那里有钱，而且那里的人们对这场斗争感同身受。正如我们之前所说，科利尔高地的许多人直接来自斗争一线。他们是奋斗者，或者至少他们的父母是。所以这是一方面。另一方面，科利尔高地长期以来一直以与黑人精英的联系为荣。黑人没有理由不成为精英。所以，坚持中产阶级价值观有时会带有精英主义色彩，同时又不能显得像个精英主义者，因为那可能会背叛社区的精神，这是一件微妙的事情。
Yeah. Yeah. How does race tie into all this talk of elitism and trying to like create a space, but also not make it an exclusive space because exclusive space is the very thing that you're trying to get away from. Tie this all together for me because it's really complex. It is complex and historian Maurice Hoppsen helped me understand some of this. We talked a lot about race and class and he said, there's something unique about how they intersect in a city like Atlanta, especially during Jim Crow, which is when Black call your heights
是的。种族是如何与所有这些关于精英主义的讨论联系在一起的？试图创造一个空间，但又不能让它成为一个排他的空间，因为排他性正是你试图摆脱的东西。把这一切联系起来，因为这真的很复杂。确实很复杂，历史学家莫里斯·霍普森帮我理解了其中的一些。我们谈了很多关于种族和阶级的问题，他说，在亚特兰大这样的城市，尤其是在吉姆·克劳法时期，即黑人科利尔高地
was first being developed. There's one particular feature of the American South that basically made all Black folks know each other. And that is white supremacy and segregation, which means that you could be the richest black man in Atlanta and you could be the poorest and y'all know each other. Based on you, you live in the same spots,
最初发展的时候，它们之间的交集有一些独特之处。美国南方有一个特殊的特征，基本上让所有的黑人都互相认识。那就是白人至上主义和种族隔离，这意味着你可能是亚特兰大最富有的黑人，也可能是最贫穷的，但你们都认识彼此。因为你们住在同一个地方，
you worship at the same spots, you go to the barbershop, I mean, like, you know, you go to the Hasselon, you know, you know, who the hustler is all, you know, you just know the people. So whatever your station in life, because of the way that racism and segregation worked for so long, you were probably going to mix with other classes of black folks. And if they didn't mix, they certainly knew people and had connections and relationships and sometimes even kinfolk who were not in call your heights who were in other communities, other neighborhoods and in other class ranks.
你们在同一个地方礼拜，去同一个理发店，我的意思是，你知道，你去那个地方，你知道谁是骗子，你知道，你只是认识这些人。所以无论你的社会地位如何，由于种族主义和种族隔离长期以来的运作方式，你很可能会与其他阶层的黑人混在一起。如果他们没有混在一起，他们肯定也认识人，有联系和关系，有时甚至是有亲戚不在科利尔高地，而是在其他社区、其他街区和其他阶层中。
And so to disparage folks who aren't part of your immediate class circle, you would be potentially disparaging your own folk, your own people. And a version of you, possibly, just a couple of years ago, we've seen all these studies about how precarious wealth is when it comes to black people in America. And I think that a lot of black folks understand that they're but for the grace of God, and this little bit of scratch in my pocket, go I. And so it's important, I think, for a lot of people to maintain,
因此，贬低那些不属于你直接阶层圈子的人，你可能会贬低你自己的同胞，你的人民。而且，这可能也是几年前的你自己。我们已经看到了所有关于黑人在美国的财富是多么不稳定的研究。我认为很多黑人都明白，如果不是上帝的恩典，加上我口袋里这点钱，我可能也会那样。所以，我认为对很多人来说，保持
certainly from this older generation, to maintain some sense of respect and empathy for people who may be of a different class rank, because they're still folks. Yeah. You're talking about the nature of that balancing act, it's the sensitivity to the idea that you don't wanna come off as a litus
特别是对于这一代年长者来说，保持对不同阶层的人的尊重和同理心是很重要的，因为他们仍然是人。是的。你在谈论那种平衡行为的本质，这是一种对不想显得像精英主义者的敏感，
because a litus is an ism that is extremely close to racism and they recognize that. Right. And that's an interesting thing that they're going through, but also knowing that they want things to be a certain way. Right, right. And at least from the perspective of old school call your heights, but also knowing that they want things to be a certain way.
因为精英主义是一种与种族主义极其接近的“主义”，他们意识到了这一点。对。他们正在经历的事情很有趣，但他们也知道他们希望事情以某种方式进行。对，对。至少从老派科利尔高地的角度来看，他们知道他们希望事情以某种方式进行。
Right, right. And at least from the perspective of old school call your heights, they wanted things to be properly middle class. Partly because as they saw it, that was how they would get to a place where they could lift up the entire race. Like there's a version of elitism that could be valuable,
对，对。至少从老派科利尔高地的角度来看，他们希望事情能达到中产阶级的标准。部分原因是，在他们看来，这就是他们能够提升整个种族地位的方式。就像有一种精英主义是有价值的，
one that could actually overcome racism. And it's still tied to front yards. Now, Minette Coleman actually brought a lot of this home for me. Yeah, she's our other MC. I remember doing this in the edit that we had Mernick Clayton and Minette Coleman. We had to keep them straight. And so Minette is the daughter of George Coleman
一种真正能够克服种族主义的精英主义。而且它仍然与前草坪有关。现在，米内特·科尔曼实际上让我明白了这一点。是的，她是我们的另一位嘉宾。我记得在剪辑时，我们有默娜·克莱顿和米内特·科尔曼。我们必须把她们区分开。米内特是乔治·科尔曼的女儿，
and he wrote for the Atlanta daily world and she talked to him. And her parents, they had their house built from scratch. They had this beautiful backyard with the massive trees. And in Menette's mind, there's a through line from lawns and yards to middle class values all the way to W.E.B. Du Bois and his formula of racial uplift.
他为《亚特兰大每日世界报》撰稿，她和他谈过。她的父母，他们从零开始建造了自己的房子。他们有一个美丽的后院，种着巨大的树。在米内特的脑海中，从草坪和庭院到中产阶级价值观，一直到W.E.B.杜波依斯和他关于种族提升的公式，有一条贯穿始终的线索。
Black people talk about the fact that, you know, we're trying to be what Du Bois referred to as the talented 10. 10% of the black population is going to be responsible for raising people up. And so as Minette explains it, folks felt like if we're going to achieve that lofty goal, then we have to do all of the middle class things like stay out of the front yard, play in the back yard, and that will help create the ripest conditions for class ascent. So you never saw the children in the front yard. You sometimes you didn't even know if people had children in their house. in the front yard. You sometimes you didn't even know if people had children in their house. We played in the backyard. You played with your friends came over.
黑人谈论这样一个事实，即我们正在努力成为杜波依斯所说的“天才十分之一”。10%的黑人人口将负责提升其他人。正如米内特所解释的那样，人们觉得如果我们想要实现那个崇高的目标，那么我们就必须做所有中产阶级的事情，比如远离前院，在后院玩耍，这将有助于为阶级提升创造最成熟的条件。所以你从来没见过孩子们在前院。有时你甚至不知道人们家里是否有孩子。我们在后院玩。你和朋友过来时一起玩。
You played in your backyard. But who were your friends? Your friends were kids who were probably going to grow up and go to college and have professional jobs. And this was what our middle-class parents viewed as fulfilling the boys' prophecy for having sired members of the Talented 10th. So whenever I think of Kaya Heights, when I was a kid, I think you had to play in a backyard. Wow. Yeah. I mean, we covered lawns and the sort of politics of lawns and the sort of like ethics and design of lawns.
你在后院玩。但你的朋友是谁？你的朋友是那些可能会长大、上大学并从事专业工作的孩子。这就是我们中产阶级父母认为实现杜波依斯关于培养“天才十分之一”成员的预言的方式。所以每当我想到科利尔高地，当我还是个孩子的时候，我想你必须在后院玩。哇。是的。我的意思是，我们讨论了草坪，以及草坪的政治，还有草坪的伦理和设计。
When you add in a whole other element of race to it, when you're talking about values and mixing that all together, it gets very complicated, very quickly. You can see the balance that they're all walking. Absolutely. Roman, this is a great question for yet another episode about lawns and the suburbs and whatnot. But for several folks, including Minette, they were pretty candid about black families embracing white ideals of how to look and act and be middle class.
当你加入种族这一层因素时，当你谈论价值观并将这一切混合在一起时，事情很快就会变得非常复杂。你可以看到他们都在走的平衡木。绝对是这样。罗曼，这是一个关于草坪、郊区等等的又一集节目的好问题。但对于包括米内特在内的几个人来说，他们非常坦率地谈到了黑人家庭拥抱白人关于如何看待、表现和成为中产阶级的理想。
Right. But look, it makes sense in another way too. So call your heights is huge, and it used to be even bigger, 4,000 acres. And the thing that binds this massive space that's otherwise a pretty ordinary looking middle class suburb, the thing that binds it together is its origin story. I mean, call your heights and needs its story.
对。但看，它在另一方面也说得通。科利尔高地很大，而且过去更大，有4000英亩。将这个巨大的空间——否则它只是一个看起来很普通的中产阶级郊区——联系在一起的东西，是它的起源故事。我的意思是，科利尔高地需要它的故事。
And it needs everyone to show that they're on board with that story. And although it was a middle and upper class community, not everybody can park an expensive car or several expensive cars in their driveway. Not everybody can get a swimming pool put in, but the way that many of the folks that I spoke to saw it, what their neighbors can do is go out, get themselves a lawn mower,
它需要每个人都表现出他们认同那个故事。虽然这是一个中上阶层社区，但并不是每个人都能在车道上停一辆昂贵的车或几辆昂贵的车。并不是每个人都能安装游泳池，但按照我采访的许多人的看法，他们的邻居能做的是走出去，买一台割草机，
cut their grass, park in the driveway or on the street, definitely not on the front lawn. And in that way, they signal that they're on board with preserving this vision. Right. Right. I can totally see that. That that's the, that's the payment for entry. It doesn't have to be the biggest house. It doesn't have to be the nicest car. But, you know, if you deserve to be there, you are supposed to. Moe Yelons. Well, this was great. Thanks a lot Chris.
割草，把车停在车道上或街上，绝对不能停在前草坪上。通过这种方式，他们表明他们认同保护这一愿景。对，对。我完全能理解。这就是入场费。它不必是最大的房子。它不必是最好的车。但是，你知道，如果你值得在那里，你就应该这样做。莫·耶隆斯。好吧，这太棒了。非常感谢你，克里斯。
Yeah, any time, Roman. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Christopher Johnson, edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Jim Briggs, music by our director of sound, Swan Rial. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Le, Lashemadon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Rubay, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Juanita and Harold Morton of the Collier Heights Community Association, Janice Sykes Rogers, Serena McCracking of the Keenan Research Center, part of the Atlanta
是的，随时欢迎，罗曼。本周的《99%隐形》由克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作，乔·罗森伯格剪辑，吉姆·布里格斯进行技术制作，音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里亚尔创作。德莱尼·霍尔是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括薇薇安·李、拉希玛·唐、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·鲁贝、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我，罗曼·马斯。本周特别感谢科利尔高地社区协会的胡安妮塔和哈罗德·莫顿、贾妮丝·赛克斯·罗杰斯、基南研究中心的塞雷娜·麦克拉金（亚特兰大历史中心的一部分），
History Center, and Kevin Cruz, professor of history at Princeton University, and the author of White Flight, Atlanta, and the making of modern conservatism. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family. Now head court, six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org.
以及普林斯顿大学历史学教授、《白人逃离：亚特兰大与现代保守主义的形成》一书的作者凯文·克鲁兹。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在前往潘多拉大楼北六个街区，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，或关注节目@99PI org。
We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. and Syria's Exym. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。